dude that was one heck of a space it was
filthy it was filthy the boy the boys
what are you doing come on I mean your
girls worked at one heck of a speeches
they wrote it up might they have a
future in the business Adam yes they
actually do they actually do they're uh
they stayed up it was like three in the
morning I saw them furiously writing
that speech saying dad you're gonna
really hate this and here we are
it's not fun to touch don't touch it
it'll only if you say corn flakes on
your face Corn Flakes yeah I like corn
flakes but dark ones
you're looking great how are you feeling
how's how are you recovering from your
hip surgery my hip surgery was painful
yeah they went through the uh the butt
cheek so that hurt but everything yes
they can't they can't they went through
it they got to the hip everything's good
now three months later I'm feeling
pretty solid you're gonna be hitting the
courts anytime soon I'm nervous about
that I haven't done that yet but I want
to I want to play sooner hopefully that
works out yeah now what are are we going
to see you on the morning show because
we love your friendships right that'd be
great
monologues are so long
Afghanistan no Anderson knows if if
there's something over a page I'm in
trouble whatever yeah no no no but yeah
that'd be amazing I know we we
wanted Adam make it happen Jennifer and
I did a movie that's coming out in March
another murder mystery and then maybe
when we do press for that I'll bother
about being on her show I love it I'll
bug her about it thank you thank you you
know tonight we were celebrating the Arc
of your work and the journey that you've
taken to get where you are today
congratulations sir thank you what does
this award that looks unlike other
Awards on your mantle and at home it's
not a blimp it's not popcorn what does
this bad boy mean to you it's cool man
it was very uh nice of it's nice of
anybody to even think of you this way
and uh and I've been to this award show
a couple times it's fun nice people
everyone has a great time it celebrates
new new artists and that's fun to be
around and uh the fact that they gave
this to me is cool it's cool it's just
good good stuff thank you you're a cool
guy of all the films that you've done is
there one that makes you most proud
uh you know I I don't know I don't know
I have such a good time making them I'm
with these whoever I make the movies
with we believe in them and work hard
and hang out together and it becomes uh
uh very passionate thing
very passionate thing he's funny by the
way he's such a nice guy
um anyways yeah no they all mean a lot
to me
[Music]